how's it going everybody just a quick
reminder before we dive into the video
that the Avengers infinity war blu-ray
giveaway still continues if you would
like to enter all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero Tony Stark
stated in Avengers infinity war that
Thanos had been stuck inside of his head
for the past six years since he sent an
army to New York he was also given a
very haunting vision from The Scarlet
Witch in Avengers age of Ultron since
these events Tony has been preparing for
an alien invasion after all that's why
Tony attempted to create Ultron in the
first place but we all know how that
ended and then in the vision that he had
thanks to the scarlet witch's telepathic
powers he saw all of his fellow Avengers
dead not only that but Captain America
grabbed him and said you could have
saved us why didn't you do more since
then Tony has been haunted and tortured
by the events of the Battle of New York
and the vision he saw where it was
apparent that the rest of the Avengers
died because of him so when Tony says
that Thanos has been in his head over
the past six years what he's really
saying is that since the events of the
Battle of New York Tony has been
tortured with the memories and the
thoughts of what happened and since the
vision he has been tortured with living
in fear that an alien invasion would
come and all of his friends would die
since then Tony has been preparing
through all of these years for an alien
invasion and his response and defense
was nanotechnology and nano tech
probably would have been enough against
any other villain except the mad Titan
in the end it wasn't enough and his
greatest fear essentially came true
although his exact vision did not come
true half of the universe ended up
getting wiped away from existence and
Tony could not stop it from happening
this is what Tony lived in fear of over
all these years what torch
him over all these years and he prepared
for this moment to be able to prevent it
from happening but he couldn't and this
is where his true torture begins Tony
now has to live with the fact that he
failed he knew what was coming he
prepared for it and could not stop it
from happening he was not enough half of
the universe got wiped out from
existence and Tony is going to blame
himself he will start thinking of
what-ifs
what if the sokovia accords didn't
happen what if the Avengers were not
split up and he did not go against Steve
Rogers what if the Avengers were still
all together and they all went and get
stano's together could they all have
defeated him what if he never got Peter
Parker involved could that have somehow
made it to where he did not turn to dust
these what-ifs are going to be what
truly haunts him could he have done
things differently could he have done
more his worst fear came to life
Avengers died half of the universe died
and he's wondering if he could have done
more and one of the greatest tortures to
Tony is that he survived his failure but
what if this failure is actually what
makes the feeding Thanos and Avengers
four possible why did the one scenario
that doctor strain saw where they
Avengers won ultimately have to start
with their defeat why did it involve
half of the Avengers dying and Doctor
Strange and spider-man dying but Tony
Stark staying alive perhaps it was
because in their current timeline that
they existed there actually was no way
to win and the only way to defeat Thanos
was to change events that happened in
the past such as the Battle of New York
age of Ultron and the civil war between
the Avengers and perhaps Tony Stark is
the only person that could change these
events a person like Tony Stark
can't accept failure it'll eat him alive
more than anything especially when that
failure involves half of the universe
dying so Tony will set out and try to
figure out a way to undo his failures in
which there really are only two one you
could get the Infinity Gauntlet from
Thanos and use it to undo his snap or to
go back in time seeing as how Tony Stark
Doctor Strange spider-man and half of
the guardians of the galaxy just got
their butts kicked by Thanos I don't
think he thinks
one is possible not to mention nobody
probably knows where Thanos is so that
leaves option number two time travel and
for a person like Tony Stark that's
probably not too far out of reach
time travel is pretty much all but
confirmed for Avengers for anyways so
this is most likely the route that he
goes down especially with the help from
Scott Lang it's been widely speculated
that they will not figure out how time
travel works until years after the
events of Avengers infinity war this
will give Tony Stark plenty of time to
figure out what events in the past he
needs to change in order to make
defeating Thanos a possibility leaked
set photos for Avengers four have
already shown us the possibility of the
Avengers going back to the Battle of New
York and the events of Civil War if all
ends up to be true Tony Stark will have
several years to decide what events he
needs to undo and where exactly he needs
to go back in time with the ultimate
goal of changing events in the past to
where the future is set up to where they
could possibly defeat Thanos
so ultimately Tony's suffering and
torture will lead to the Avengers being
able to defeat Thanos in Avengers 4 I
think that this is all part of the one
single scenario where the Avengers win
that Doctor Strange saw clearly Tony
Stark was supposed to survive and is a
key to this one scenario and the
Avengers not being able to win in the
current timeline that they exist in
would set up time travel and Avengers
for quite nicely let me know your
thoughts on this do you think that
Tony's failures will ultimately lead to
the Avengers defeating Thanos and do you
think that time travel will be the key
to the Avengers victory let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
the giveaway still continues if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win a copy of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thanks for
watching
woof woof
you